What do you say?
I want you to be my VP.
I want you, you're my Vice.
Well, George, I uh...
I'm a CEO of a large company.
And I have been Secretary of Defense.
And I have been White House Chief of Staff.
The Vice Presidency is a mostly symbolic job.
Uh huh.
However, if we came to a uh...
different...
understanding...
And I can handle the more mundane...jobs.
Overseeing bureaucracy,
military,
energy,
and um,
foreign policy.
Yeah, right.
I like that.
When you have power, people will always try to take it from you.
Always.
Are you even more ruthless than you used to be?
So we gonna do this thing, or what? I mean, is this happening?
I believe...
we can make this work.
[laughing] hot damn.